e aí
e imagina então vocês amanhã todos vocês
receberem uma mensagem em alguma rede
social com um convite muito estranho
importante um convite de um desconhecido
que alguém que vocês não conhecem
definitivamente assim o convite assim oi
estou chegando na sua cidade amanhã e eu
quero me encontrar com você o quê vocês
fariam a estranho né todas essas pessoas
que estão nessa imagem de oito países
diferentes receberam esse convite nos
últimos três meses ele tem recebido esse
convite nos últimos três meses receber
um convite assim realmente é um tanto
quanto estranha a primeira reação é é um
golpe é spam não vou responder vou
deletar é muito mais fácil a gente e
seguir a vida e não cair nisso não sair
da nossa zona
a ignorar totalmente esse convite só que
essas 8 horas pessoas leram convite e
responderam aliás essas todas essas
pessoas desses oito desses oito a cidade
essas 40 pessoas para as quais esse
convite foi enviado elas responderam
responderam sim elas aceitaram se
encontrar com desconhecido no dia
seguinte em suas cidades por exemplo o
gep que é esse moço ele mora na ilha da
tasmânia e respondeu sim mais do que
isso ele ele foi sozinho nesse encontro
e essa moça a área ela mora em que ela
vive ela respondeu sim também mas eu
acho que ela tava com um pouco pé atrás
ela levou o namorado mas ela foi e essa
de amarelo é up we up we mora em
joanesburgo ela falou assim ah sei mas
pode ser no meu bairro na minha cidade
que as oito e ela levou uma amiga todos
eles responderam sim menos o cris o cris
não recebeu esse convite
e ele foi abordado no meio da rua por um
estranho e esse estranham abordou ele
quando ele tava dançando no meio de uma
praça em santo domingo no domingo um
grupo de dança uma caixa de som estranho
abordou ele interessado na que ele tava
fazendo e fez o convite você trataria se
juntar comigo amanhã para gente fazer um
vídeo junto a possibilidade de isso
acontecer com vocês e vocês falarem não
muito obrigada pelo amor de deus fique
longe de mim aí na hora certa a gente se
assusta com uma ponte assim então
evasivo talvez ou tão descarado ou tão
verdadeiro
e o chris ouviu essa ponte
ah e falou eu topo eu topo me encontrar
assim e a prova desse encontro tá aí ó o
cris não só topou mas como levou várias
outras pessoas para se juntar isso
desconhecido que fez o convite na
verdade são dois de ana e eu e por que
que a gente tem feito isso nos últimos
três meses feito convites para estranhos
para se juntar no meio da rua e fazer um
vídeo junto
é porque a gente se perguntou esse criar
vídeo colaborações isso a gente juntar
com as pessoas que a gente não conhece e
se a gente fizer isso puder fazer com
que a gente cria relações de confiança
para as pessoas faça com que a gente
possa se aproximar mais desconhecidos
e foi por isso que a gente começou a
fazer esse projeto essa série o ar ele
ficou leve a gente decidiu ser um
experimento a gente decidiu ser uma
cobaia da nossa própria experiência e a
gente tem viajado muito para provar isso
e uma coisa que a gente pode ir com
certeza dizer depois de ter dado a volta
ao mundo gravando colaborações com
pessoas que a gente nunca viu é que tem
muita gente no mundo que a gente nunca
viu e todos eles são estranhas até
aqueles deixem de ser hoje todas essas
pessoas que vocês viram são nossos
amigos não são mais estranhos para a
gente tem impacto a gente pensou que a
gente precisava de movimento
oi e para a gente tem pacto a gente
precisava de contato com ele ficou leve
conta essa história da nossa de sair das
da nossa zona de conforto de
proporcionar movimento para que a gente
consiga de fato mudar uma situação que a
gente achava que dava para fazer a gente
acha que com colaborações assim a gente
criar redes de confiança a gente cria
uma possibilidade de vida e de bem-estar
maior e eu tenho certeza absoluta por
prova e experiência própria de que a
gente é muito mais feliz quando vê as
redes se formando e as pessoas sendo
conectadas na nossa própria rede e a
gente terminou o projeto semana passada
e o último episódio da série que foi
rodar em manaus ainda não estreou
estressa semana e a gente fez um
trechinho para vocês
o jogo do da série e ver em primeira mão
a nossa colar de um trechinho da collab
de manaus depois de sete cidades sete
chico leves a gente chega ao destino
final da nossa volta ao mundo que é
manaus am
bom então e aí a gente só tem essa
questão que a gente tem poucos dias aqui
para fazer isso então que vocês quiserem
a gente tem moleque de coisas oferecendo
porque essas cinco ou pode pensar para
nossas falaram não sei de pegar cada um
de um grupo tá gostando a gente que tem
que incrível olha só o que se propor a
se conectar com desconhecidos pode fazer
com a gente tipo olha só a gente foi
parar lá
o que vocês acham que isso é meio louco
mas é gostoso né só para fazer parte
disso nosso objetivo com o colégio ela
provar que quando a gente se conecta com
desconhecidos para realizar no desafio
juntos a gente cria relações de
confiança a gente se aproxima das
pessoas e que isso pode ter um impacto
muito positivo na forma como a gente
vive depois três meses na estrada a
gente concluir nosso desafio e agora sim
a gente pode dizer que a gente foi uma
experiência muito bem sucedida a gente
escolheu a arte como ferramenta para se
conectar com desconhecidos
ah mas foi a nossa forma a gente espera
que essa série posso inspirar mais
pessoas a colaborar a se conectar e a
enxergar o estranho com novos pontos de
vista desconectar tão longe você iria
para provar algo que você acredita a
gente deu a volta ao mundo
bom obrigada tá
e aí